in this world that we cover feelings
will trump facts or science or research
at any moment if this thing makes me
feel good then i'm going to trust that
and that's how cult leaders have gotten
people to leave their families and come
into their groups because they feel
something that they weren't getting
elsewhere
derek barris welcome to the show thanks
chris appreciate you uh reaching out and
having me on
so i got all happy and proud of myself
uh over the last couple of years or so
because i'd noticed a mechanism
occurring where
um
spiritual yoga moms far-left spiritual
yoga moms and sort of right-wing trolls
appeared to be horseshoeing some of
their world views um to
uh coalesce online and i was all sort of
pleased with myself that i'd unearthed
this kind of interesting dynamic that i
thought was going on and then it turns
out that this is quite a well-known um
dynamic that has been going on a
mechanism that's been occurring for
quite a while which has a term
conspirituality which describes the
overlap of conspiracy theories with
spirituality typically of new age
varieties contemporary con spirituality
became common in the 1990s apparently
yes i actually wouldn't say it was that
well known even today i tracked the term
on twitter and there are constantly
people who are just discovering the
terms so i wouldn't feel bad
about
having stepped into this world in such a
manner
it was academically coined in 2011
by charlotte ward and david voas but it
really didn't get a lot of traction as a
paper until the very just before the
pandemic began actually a philosopher
from the uk named jules evans
wrote a medium article where he
unearthed that term and that's how i
found out about it and then i wrote a
subsequent article for a publication i
used to work for called big think
and that eventually led to the podcast
of that name so
it's really
it it it we can look back in reflection
and trace it back to the 60s we can
trace it back honestly to the beginning
of the 19th century with emma emerson
and throws work
but
it really still is a new concept that i
think a lot of people are trying to wrap
their heads around although i think the
precursors
you know in hindsight everything makes
sense and you can trace them back from
there yeah well i think one of the
interesting things in 2022 especially is
that calling something a conspiracy
theory seems to be
quite problematic now so after a few
decades of using it to refer to sort of
all manner of crimes whether it's rumors
or misinformation or disinformation or
general [ __ ] by the government or
corporate media that ends up being
proven as true or not being proven is
true it's kind of
memed and legitimated the term
into a particularly weird place and it's
it's almost a little bit useless now as
far as i can see
i remember i interviewed for my older
podcast before con spirituality which
called earthrise i got to talk to dan
carlin of hardcore history
and i remember asking him specifically
when historians 100 years from now look
back at this time
how are they going to be able to
make sense of what was going on with so
much information and his idea was that
the cream always rises to the top
and i think his work has you know
shown that in a lot of ways given how
diligent he is with what he does but
we're in a completely new environment
now
and i agree with you that the term
conspiracy theory is overused in a lot
of ways it still has validity and there
are still
real world examples we can point to
about it but everything gets so jumbled
when everyone has a voice and there's so
much misinformation and disinformation
that floats around that you can never
really identify where the source
material comes from
that it's completely disorienting when
you're looking at your feed and seeing
all that information come through to
identify
what are the actual conspiracies
what are what have levels of truth in
them that we should explore further and
what is purely just trolling to see if
we can get traction yeah the interesting
thing i suppose about dan is that being
a historian
he is going to be looking
retrospectively and it's easy to say oh
the cream rises to the top with the
benefit of hindsight because the stuff
that wasn't true tends to kind of decay
and fall off but when you're in the
midst of it every different
proposal of a description about how
reality exists kind of seems like it
might be equally possibly true
yeah and for the most part there is a
common
understanding in history that the
winners write the history yeah so
so even then you're dealing with source
material that is coming from a side uh
for the most part i think if you
actually go back to the precursors of
written language with hieroglyphs or
different forms of uh you know
currencies or things that we we can
speculate on we can actually piece
together a better understanding because
historians have more to work with but as
soon as you start getting to memoirs
and
government sponsored written logs then
you're going to be skewed in one
direction or the other so it's it's
extremely exciting to look back at
history but it's also quite challenging
what types of people would you say are
the most vulnerable to
conspiracy theories or conspiratorial
thinking
and or the intersection with the
spirituality elements as well
well i'll answer that in two ways i'll
go abroad and then a little more towards
conspiracy the broad one is
this isn't uh you know a 100 bullet
proof but in general it's often people
without strong social support networks
if you're spending a lot of your time
online and you're disconnected from your
tribe or your groups or the people that
you're around that can check you
then you know it's very easy to get
indoctrinated into any sort of
ideologies
one reason where you know i've worked in
fitness in the wellness industry for
decades
and one reason i feel like that i never
fell into any sort of rabbit hole was
because i have a large network of
friends from a wide
group from many different groups and
anytime i would float something that
seemed a little ridiculous i would get
called out
and that's really important like those
checks and balances are necessary and
even though everything's feel so close
because of these
you know i've never met you in person
we're just meeting now but you know we
can have rapport and build a
relationship from this and that gives a
false sense of security that doesn't
actually necessarily exist
so those real world connections the lack
of them make people very vulnerable to
conspiracies
now specifically to conspiratuality and
the wellness
influencers and people who are
indoctrinated into these ideas
the language that has been going on in
yoga studios since i began my practice
and study in the mid 90s
has always
veered toward what we now recognize as
this merging meaning the idea that for
example
you know your body best you're your own
doctor
your brain is your own pharmacy
all these ideas have this rhetoric has
been perpetuated throughout this
industry for a long time
so when you get to something like a
pandemic you have a community that is
generally not engaged in their local
civics they don't necessarily vote they
don't know who the representatives are
they don't really have to pay attention
to politics
and then you have a slightly privileged
class that can afford the supplements
and the nootropics and they can afford
to eat organic
well they be they get caught up in this
closed system where they feel as though
their reality is reality
and so they become very vulnerable to
conspiracy theories as well because
well if it's not affecting my life then
why should i you know it must not be
real and that's just not you know if you
look at it from a globalized perspective
that's just not how the world operates
yeah so there's kind of two
two rules or at least two on averages
here one of them being people that are
incredibly isolated and another being
people who are also kind of isolated but
isolated within a very tight sphere
community
correct yes and and it definitely
changed i always look at instagram as
the point where it changed
when i began my practice in yoga a lot
of the conversations they were local
right it started in college in new
jersey but then living in new york city
you know so the studios you'd get into
these conversations with people and the
conversations really trended around
what's the correct shoulder alignment in
downward dog or what does this yama or
niyama represent like let's talk about
the philosophy of it
in 2011 when you had this
real
uptick in people showing off the poses
uh and then branding them and then
selling their supplements and whatever
that whatever courses online whatever
they're doing on their instagram feed
that created a real different dynamic
and it did introduce more people to yoga
in different practices but at the same
time
it made it very about the image and the
lifestyle instead of the practice and
that's where
eventually things like humanon slipped
into the hashtags and was able to
infiltrate that community hang on q anon
infiltrated the yoga community oh
absolutely that's really the roots of
the podcast in many ways okay talk to me
about that
well
so as i said
i began my career in journalism as a
local news reporter in 1997 and i would
cover zoning board meetings and school
board meetings and go to the politicians
houses and knock on their doors and it's
that is where politics really happens we
we get caught up in the you know the the
what's ever happening on twitter but it
still happens regionally
and what i noticed as i entered the
wellness community in space again is
this lack of political dis
engagement and so when the pandemic
happened you have a community that is
highly disengaged from politics
especially local politics
highly disengaged from public health
because we haven't had any serious
pandemics or anything of nature in our
lifetime
and
all they had was their
news sources which were usually social
media feeds which depended upon the
people that you followed
the term pastel q anon was introduced
around the time at the beginning of the
pandemic to show how
far-right conspiracy theories started
infiltrating into wellness community
through hashtags and that specifically
happened through
what was happening in the chans on q
anon and the first point of infiltration
was actually with 5g this idea that 5g
was causing kovid that was david ike's
sort of big contribution right he did
three or four episodes with brian rose
that broke youtube for a little bit
right and he's still on it he just
recently did a series on gaia where he's
still promoting that narrative of 5g
and the thing about 5g is it
people will only follow
any sort of conspiracy as far and as
they will until it inconveniences them
so if they pick up their phone and it
works a second faster than it used to
ultimately they're going to get forget
about 5g and the same thing is going to
happen with 6g7 it's going to keep
happening and people are going to forget
it because they have short attention
spans and because the technology they
want it to work as quickly as possible
so that entered the community and then
quickly kind of faded
now
as i said this was the first time in all
of our lives that we were locked in we
were forced to stay inside and if you
don't know where to look for news and
you have a distrust of certain news
sources and you're following your
influencers and they say don't look at
that look at what's happening on these
chan boards that's the real truth well
that's very seductive this idea that you
have some inside knowledge that other
people don't have that's also been
embedded in the yoga community for a
long time it's like well i can meditate
and i have this breath work practice and
i'm connecting this spirit so i have the
inside track to true spirituality
uh and so from there that the real point
of infiltration and what has perpetuated
was the anti-vaccine rhetoric which has
continued and will continue for a long
time
that ideology is not new uh it began
when louis pasteur's experiments started
with vaccines so there's always been
anti-vac sentiment but at that time that
started becoming part of the world view
oh there's there's this virus eventually
there's going to be vaccines and that's
where the microchips will come in and
that was coming from the q anon chan
boards in the feeds and then that was
fed directly into the wellness community
who have this idea of bodily sovereignty
and so that is what created this
juggernaut that we track and cover on
the podcast
it seems like um
gate kept knowledge
we have a unique insight or we are
a special group or a particularly uh
unique type of person is one of the
tropes that seems to be being used here
do conspiracies tend to have some common
themes or agendas with them that you can
kind of pick up on
the inside group knowledge is one of
them this idea that the the there are
these forces external that are trying to
oppress society in some manner and to be
clear there are our banking system is a
good example of that uh and and
healthcare has
many problems uh one of the funny
criticisms that we've gotten is that
we're shills for big pharma because we
promote vaccines
and my last book on psychedelic therapy
half of the book was
talking about all of the problems with
the pharmaceutical industry because of
mental health treatments
but everything gets scrambled when you
have the binaries that are presented on
social media and so specifically with
these groups this idea that wink wink
this is really what's going on and now
you know it so that we can share in this
that's very seductive to people
especially if their only connection is
through the technology at that time well
that's a a binding mechanism right it
makes you feel like you're a part of
something it makes you feel like you're
special
and that creates an immediate in-group
out-group dynamic
absolutely and we've even noticed that
with our podcast i mean admittedly we're
all left of center on the podcast
but even the three of us don't agree on
certain topics and we'll express that
and even within our
uh our listenership if we stray too far
off of something that a certain base
doesn't agree with then they come after
us it's it's um this in-group mentality
persists across the political spectrum
right now yeah it's um i i thought about
this the other day i might do a
newsletter on it that one of the
most
painful insulting
irritating things that you can do on the
internet
is to
disprove
the avatar that somebody had of you in
their head
somebody thinks that you're a particular
person
and maybe it turns out that you quite
quite weren't quite that and that is
because it's inconvenienced them they've
had to face the potential that they're
untrue and there's another part of this
which is
something i think jordan peterson does
get right where he says that um when
people live in archetypes what we're
able to do if we can if we know one view
that a person holds and we can
accurately predict everything else that
that person holds it makes them quite
predictable they're actually quite a
safe person to be around because you
don't there's no nuance there's no
danger of them deviating from one thing
so when you've got this projection
around the direction that you think that
derek or chris are going to go in
and then they deviate from that you
actually think oh hang on a second maybe
this person isn't as trustworthy as i
thought that they were now it's not
about trust it's about the fact that you
easily want to be able to predict their
behavior in future but i
my bro science idea is that that plays a
role in it as well
i was listening recently to uh sam
harris had a round table and david frum
and applebaum george packer were
involved but david frum said he has a
rule which is if he's on twitter and he
sees someone whose name he doesn't know
he doesn't then go start talking about
that person
but that doesn't really exist in a lot
of twitter culture or social media
culture i mean um he wouldn't take a
single instance of what that person says
is a representative right okay yeah
correct yes exactly well put what a
terrifyingly reasonable way to exist
uh i don't know um you know i i've read
peterson i've covered him for big think
i haven't been happy with uh certain
directions so i don't know that
particular uh quote from him so i can't
comment on that but the idea behind it
of of of yes this it's basically
you imprint onto these figures and
influences that you have and then when
you realize that they're not thinking
exactly everything that's in your head
well i mean
in general humans would then be able to
discuss debate and dialogue
i've been involved in some serious
attacks or debates online and i'm like
if we were all together in the same room
this would never go down this way i have
never once been in a situation of
discussion among people that left in the
same manner that happens on social media
and i understand that their different
dynamics and technology does that but i
really think about every time i post or
say something i think if i was in the
room with them right now would i say it
this way
and also what else do you lose this
happened recently because i made some
comments on joe rogan that weren't
appreciated by all of our listeners and
the way that i
wrote it
then it was in my voice
and the way it was read
were different and i get that because
you don't get inflections you don't get
pantomimes you can't see the expression
you get forget sarc i'm a very sarcastic
person i'm always fielding stuff about
sarcasm because uh just on twitter alone
if you don't know me you'll read in a
completely different way and that's
that's a real challenge when operating
in these structures and trying to trying
to
you know provide valuable information to
spark conversation with people but not
to be taken in a complete 180 of what
you actually were intending to say it's
it's challenging well this feeds into
the in-group out group tribalism
mentality right that you can what
everybody is always looking to do and i
don't want to call i learned about the
purity spiral and i'm always hesitant
about learning a new heuristic and then
trying to apply it to everything because
it's kind of like whatever the new toy
that you've got and you want to kind of
make it like that but i do think that
there's i do think there's an element of
this
where
everybody uh many people online
are bound together
by mutual distaste of an out group more
than they are mutual love of an in-group
and i think that there was some stats
around this to do with if you looked at
voting um patterns in 2012
people were more passionate about their
hatred of the other than they were about
the love of the the one that they voted
for so democrats were more distasteful
of conservatives than they were liking
of democrats and the same was true
vithursa um but that makes
the group
very fragile
right it's a very very fragile way to
hold any sort of community together
because you're constantly vigilant
you're always on the lookout for who
might be the next heretic or who might
be the next person and another part of
this that jonathan hate talks about in
the happiness hypothesis is he says that
um
the reason that we love scandal and
outrage is that it allows us to feel the
moral emotion of outrage and superiority
whilst having done nothing moral to earn
it
so we get to see somebody else do
something that is wrong
and we get to stand our morality stands
on the shoulders of a person that's
[ __ ] up while no one looks at us
so i think that there's two dynamics
there that are maybe playing a bit of a
role absolutely and and hate people
tried to cancel hate and
he who has contributed greatly to uh our
understanding of of evolutionary
psychology and biology
um
that
that
i i love technology my father was a
computer programmer starting in the 60s
i grew up around it i work full-time in
cryptocurrency i've worked in that field
for about five years i think the
applications of technology are wonderful
but they we have to know the limitations
and the failures when it comes to
communication
and the this this group mentality and
not to say i haven't gotten caught up in
a two i mean i've had to check myself in
the past as well
i hope at least that what i bring to the
podcast in my work is informed by the
work that i've done in the real world
having spent decades in journalism
having worked specifically in world
music and having gotten to travel around
and working with a lot of artists across
the world and understanding that not
everyone sees america the way that they
americans see america for example was
very illuminating to me when you get
outside
and trying to bring that perspective and
you were so right with the avatar thing
especially when they don't even have
their photo or name on them it's like
you're screaming at a void right now and
all that's going to do is increase your
cortisol and your frustration and make
you not sleep at night instead of
actually pushing any conversations
forward and it takes your eye off of
what's really important with if you want
to actually impact society in positive
ways
it's not going to happen by screaming at
someone on twitter
speaking of america and how it's seen by
the rest of the world do you think that
america as a nation is more
conspiratorial on average is it the most
conspiratorial in the world
i i don't know about most i can speak
through the lens of conspiracy and our
listenership and some data that we found
so we tend from people who reach out to
us our listenership is predominantly
america canada
the uk and australia for example and a
lot of the what we call conspirituality
happens in those countries as well as in
sort of uh let's say colonized refuges
like costa rica or bali where
white or europeans or americans have
gone and basically started yoga communes
so a lot of the thinking happens in
those areas
i would say that
privilege is often an indicator of
conspiracy conspiracy not overall by the
way but specific to cons the wellness
industry
because as i referenced earlier people
who have a certain usual middle to upper
middle and above class lifestyle
just basically defaults to believing
well why can't everyone have this and
that happens on the left and the right
that's you know that cuts across the
board
and to be clear i'm speaking in broad
strokes right now there are people
within all sorts of demographics that
don't fit that bill but from what we've
noticed
conspiracy will often happen in in these
countries um and i will also point to
something that is very apparent right
now and it it flares up at times like
what we've just happened the convoy and
the freedom of in america being around
masks and vaccines and then something
like ukraine happens um it really is a
is a sound gut check to remind
americans what democracy is and while
it's in no way perfect and needs a lot
of help that
look at what happens in countries where
you don't have some of those freedoms
and don't be so quick to judge and then
just stand on a soapbox like listen to
what other people from other places are
saying and they usually tend to be
not as white and not as privileged
one of the things that we've seen over
the last two years has been a kind of a
veil lifting at least with regards to me
of my my faith in media and and the
powers that be and stuff because i think
you know they've
uh
they [ __ ] up a bunch of times
and a lot of the time people have
commented on this as look you totally
shouldn't trust them however
look at how many creators online that
have got platforms have just jumped from
one grift to the next without a second
thought and i i can't remember who it
was someone put this really i think it
was tim kennedy who put this really
famous um meme up about um last week i
was a vaccine expert and this week i'm
an expert in international relations and
public policy from for ukraine but the
reason that that's so funny is that it
is such a trope
and i think that that you know just if
you're going to use a heuristic to try
and think about the sort of people that
you're taking or
media organizations right that you're
taking your information from online
no one is a specialist in everything
and people need to have humility around
not knowing the thing
i'm going to guess that another hallmark
of
uh
conspiracy leaders
is a
a sense of
like omnipresent omnipotent
um
understanding and insight into kind of
pretty much everything that they need to
right exactly and that was again
apparent in what's happening in ukraine
we just our last week's episode was
spirituality go to goes to war which was
covering all of the influencers and so
let's look at that through two layers
first of all
they've had a lot of the spotlight on
them for their rhetoric for the past two
years and now all of a sudden the news
is focused elsewhere
they're monetizing their streams they're
like hey this is the attention economy
we need to stay relevant so we're just
going to start waxing poetic about
ukraine which is the second thing about
just saying things that don't make any
sense so one thing that we identified
often were people saying things like
war only happens when you're divided
internally right and that it's such
nonsense
um basically
that i okay so stepping back in the yoga
sphere
you've had events happen for decades
things like
meditations for world peace the idea
that if enough people got together and
meditated the rest of the world would
feel the energy and then they would
relax all of the problems there's some
run to burn [ __ ] oh yeah yeah absolutely
very influential in this community
and so
so the the idea that you're split
internally is that either you have some
psychic rift meaning that your thoughts
are not strong enough to create the
reality that you wanted to create or
that
looking at world leaders that they're
not spiritual enough and they're only
doing this because they don't have the
empathy and the compassion for the
society oh that happens to be
uh developed through the practices that
i have accomplished and so they'll just
put out these messages on social media
with [ __ ] like that and then put
that forward as truth and
i i want to pull on something else you
said there which relates
i think that the term mainstream media
is just nonsense in many ways
having worked in again local
reporting for a number of years
media entities are competing
organizations they're not all together
in cahoots trying to like
put forward an agenda
that said
the
necessity of breaking news as quickly as
possible before anyone else has created
very bad incentives for the industry
that so i'm not giving them a free pass
but
if you are and i am i'm just making up a
number here if you're the new york times
and you have a million dollar readers i
think it's above that but you know their
twitter following whatever you know
something of that nature and then you're
someone with a podcast and i'm just
pulling rogan out because i know the
number of 12 million monthly listeners
you're a media figure at that time and
if you have i mean we have
370 000 downloads a month for our
podcast for example we're putting
forward media and
i take that seriously
from my training in terms of trying to
provide the correct information
so
the idea that all of the media is in
cahoots and just putting forward bad
messaging it doesn't actually happen it
depends on where your attention is
focused
because all of this is media at this
point you have established organizations
you have organizations with specific
incentives and then you have people who
are just kind of making [ __ ] up and then
putting it forward and trying to discern
what actually floats to the top there is
is is its own challenge but to just
label it as all the one thing it's
usually presented as
the organizations that i don't agree
with are all in cahoots oh but i'll
share an article from here because
that's the real thing and then that's
its own problem with our media
environment
i think you're right
what i
i think what i probably meant there was
that there is a particular standard that
you expect corporate press to be held to
because they're the ones that have been
doing it for the most amount of time
they're the ones that are supposed to be
adhering to journalistic standards
they're the ones that have got the most
number of researchers and so on and so
forth so um in the back of my mind
i have an increased degree of skepticism
when i read
some fellas sub stack
versus when i read something
on a big media outlet and therefore i
hold that media outlet to a higher
standard which means that it's more easy
for them to fail at meeting that
standard you know and as well i think
it's a trickle-down effect of seeing
certain government officials you know
maybe anthony fauci would like the mask
thing it's like one example i've not got
into kovid really at all on the show um
i'm not bothered about
trying to politicize that but the um
flip-flopping around masks is like a
fairly obvious example where you have
somebody that's in a position of
authority that has kind of very publicly
fallen flat on their face and kind of
changed their messaging a little bit and
one of the causes of that for me has
been um an increasing or a lack of faith
right in the powers that be knowing what
they're actually supposed to be doing
and then you think okay well if maybe if
they don't know and they make mistakes i
had this
i think this is quite a british thing
they're quite quite an orderly um nation
i had a lot of faith sort of two and a
half years ago that the people in power
knew what they were doing and maybe
during times of non-crisis they broadly
they're better presumably in case of
chaos you're going to be more difficult
uh however
the last couple of years really has kind
of exposed some of the um ineptitude i
think of i mean in the uk we've had
like the guy that's in charge of public
health snogging his secretary on cctv
and you know the dude that was the
communications like um
guy or like the right hand of boris
johnson going up to barnet castle to do
whatever like just
the very humanizing of a lot of the
errors that people in positions of power
were making remind you that they're just
as fallible and idiotic as you probably
are which kind of breaks that deminus
thing and i held them in high steam and
now maybe a little bit less and that
then trickles down to press two and you
think well hang on i had this really
really high standard that i was holding
everybody to
and then maybe not so much so perhaps
the water line of what i expect um an
independent producer i have a degree of
skepticism around them which is tuned up
and i wouldn't have done previously with
regards to the corporate press and then
now with that as well i'm thinking oh
god does anyone know what they're
talking about
well you that's good that you have that
level of discernment i would argue that
a lot of people don't
in terms of differentiating between the
standards of a new york times or a
sub-stack and even looking where the
sub-stack comes from because some of
them are
funded by media organizations which is
fine it's just a different platform but
looking at the the bonafides of the
people writing them is also important
and you also bring up a good point about
public health the public health
communication there were blunders and
some of them were expectable because
science
is always changing or our understanding
of things are always changing especially
when you have a novel virus we're trying
to figure it out and part of my issue is
that there have been mistakes and then
sometimes we'll see the influencers
continue to hold up these old mistakes
that were already admitted to and moved
on from at least there were apologies
for and being like okay we know better
now but still holding them up as
indicative of no this is oh this has
been part of the plan all along and see
how they were manipulating us
and no again
the level of humility that exists in the
yoga and wellness world is
very there's not much humility there and
from the very least the the at some of
the figures not all the figures but
those experts
do come clean when they they mess up
even recently matt taibi uh you know was
just like okay i messed up i did not
expect
um russia to invade and i wrote all
these things and i messed up with that
and i'm like okay i don't agree with you
on some things but that's good that you
can see that and if there was more of
that that would be very helpful from all
of the different vectors that you were
pointing out
the problem with that and this was
something that i learned from douglas
murray he said that any time that you
concede that you've done something wrong
or that you don't adhere to the um
ideological
projection that your side has it's seen
by the other side
as a [ __ ] in your armor and as your own
side as a lack of conviction towards
like the whatever the purpose is or the
the party line um and i think that it
very much causes people to know in the
back of their mind that if i admit that
i'm wrong this is going to be a vector
of attack for the people that are
against me
and it's going to be a signal of
um
non-loyalty or non-compliance or
whatever to the people that are supposed
to be on my side too because it's this
very kind of rough-hewn
um
[Music]
discourse that we have online and it's
very sort of you said earlier on very
binary thinking you're either with us or
you're against us
and again not how you would act in
person forgiveness is such a powerful
human connection
saying i'm sorry when you're in the room
with someone and actually meaning it
that brings healing with it and that can
let people move forward
but one one incident um so that what i
mentioned earlier about the rogan tweet
that i had it was
it basically had to do with
like all of the different arrows that
were coming at him from all different
directions at once and i was sort of
fixated on the coveted misinformation
and
my point was being like let's focus
because part of the problem with the
left is that they don't
focus
long enough on issues whereas
the right tends to sustain issues for
generations and has the discipline to be
able to do that and not that they're
perfect at it either with social media
and such but that does that is more
indicative of that particular political
leaning
and one thing that i noticed when i
released it was a number of people
saying if you just apologize we'll
forgive you
and i'm like
but i don't not believe what i said
so you're asking me to apologize for
something that is i'm actually not sorry
for
and you can't so you can't create actual
progress emotionally or intellectually
in these mediums if you can't have
actual conversations what they're after
there is fealty
right yes that's what they want they
want fealty give me so explain to me
what conspiracy theories or con
spirituality cults what do they offer
the people that follow them
uh i would say a sense of in-group
mentality as we've identified and i
think that
virtual reality will offer new forms of
indoctrination i don't want to get too
far from your question but as we look at
how these technologies are working
one thing that has existed for a long
time in colts is the ice the eye gaze
right the the cult leader who will stare
in your eyes for long periods of time to
invoke some sort of emotional response
this is well founded in the cult
literature and that doesn't translate as
well on social media but you can
identify it with some of the yogis who
are just like they're the light is right
here they have a halo and they're locked
into you the whole time
and i think that will further as we get
to augmented reality and virtual reality
uh so that's the method that's one of
the methods that they'll use um they
they offer that feeling of i'm with you
right i'm with you right now and and you
alone um we're working on an episode on
russell brand who uses this technique
and we've identified that he's actually
used it for a long time but there's that
feeling of camaraderie that exists there
uh and in general it also has to do with
verifying pre-existing beliefs
there are serious problems with our
agricultural system and our food system
our supply chain there are serious
problems with our public health
and medicine in general especially in a
capitalist system
taken to the extreme though
you have this fancified notion of i'm
only eating food that i grow
the supplements that i know that come
from this culture that respect their
indigenous people that i'm taking and
putting it into you mentioned the purity
spiral before
purity
is probably one of the biggest
ideas that pervades
these influences that we're talking
about
my sovereign body
i know what's best and the purification
of that body the purification of
thoughts
as well as bodily representation
is
very seductive to people who get caught
up by these influencers
and then eventually get roped into their
downline on their sales on their courses
their workshops whatever it happens to
be
what
why is it that a conspiracy on its own
isn't enough now obviously you get
everything comes in different flavors
but
why is it or what extra does the
spiritual element add on to
the conspiracy
part
that that sort of gives it what more
stickiness perhaps or more effectiveness
what how does it deliver it yeah it's
the it's the feeling i just finished
next week's episode which has to do with
this idea that terrain theory is right
and germ theory is wrong and i won't get
into all the specifics of that but
beauchamp's works on terrain theory has
been disproven pasteur went out that's
what modern medicine is based on and
again leaving aside the problems with
the industries of medicine but that's
what it's based on
but if you think about terrain theory
which basically posits that
you the germs only make you sick if your
environment or your thought patterns are
off if you're not living a specific
lifestyle or there are environmental
conditions that are off not that you and
i are hanging out in a room and you
sneeze and i end up taking that into my
body right it has to do with something
metaphysical
right well that invokes
a feeling
and in this world that we cover feelings
will trump facts or science or research
at any moment if this thing makes me
feel
good then i'm going to trust that and
that's coming from the brick and mortar
cults that's how cult leaders have
gotten people to leave their families
and come into their groups because they
feel something that they weren't getting
elsewhere and that is also what's
happening now in in these
online tribes where you never know what
the other end of that avatar is going
through you don't know their isolation
you don't know their family dynamic
we've received hundreds of people who've
lost family members
and they are no longer in contact
divorces
child separation like there's a lot of
people who've lost people over this time
and it usually has to do with that
feeling of
the what the other person was providing
for them
you talk a good bit about yoga and
buddhist groups as well
i would have thought
my experience with buddhism and yoga
practice
dissolving of the ego letting go of the
self all that sort of stuff it seems
like
it seems quite
anti to what i would have presumed
would have occurred in these groups so
how is it that that's coming about
well you're talking about being already
if you're entering the dissolution of
ego for example you're already halfway
up of maslow's pyramid right so you've
already have the basics taken care of uh
you you know to think about it from the
triune brain model you're not in this
you're not in the the um
the spinal cord stem anymore you're
you're up in the prefrontal cortex at
this time so you're you're living in a
way that you can start to you have the
comforts of survival already taken care
of
now the problem is
again looking specifically at the the
pandemic and then all of a sudden you
know i go to yoga at 10 o'clock then i
go to brunch with my friends and then i
do this and that wait i have to be
locked in this room well you've now
trapped me you've taken away my comfort
and my what i know as my survival
mechanisms
and so you can only reach certain states
of
being in terms of transcending
if your basics are taken care of
when someone says hey those basics no
longer exist anymore you can't buy your
toilet paper you can't whatever it
happens to be
we will very quickly revert to that
scared animal ready to lash out
and so
religion in general is always
aspirational
it provides comfort it does provide
survival mechanisms as well but when you
talk about the manifestation of yoga and
buddhist in a predominantly secular
culture in america that is predominantly
privileged in a lot of ways then you're
you're you know you are already talking
about being
part way up that pyramid and then you
take it away from them and so you're
going to see very bad behavior happen
and i think we've seen that
i'm getting a bit confused here because
it seems like on one hand
conspiracies are a um
bourgeois
indulgence uh and yet on the other hand
it's this primal response
no i i would say that uh in terms of the
bourgeois indulgence i'm speaking
specifically to spirituality and the
people we cover you know
bigfoot
aliens all of that that has existed
across the board and you can look at
them how you want so that's that i'm
speaking very specifically of the the
beat that we cover okay and the part of
the response is in
often a some sort of physical threat
that people go through i'm gonna guess
does this occur
uh when people have got maybe terminal
illness diagnoses and stuff like that as
well or
uh if people have recently gone through
grievances
um
sorry i lost the threat a little bit
there um are people more vulnerable if
that's one of the situations that's
occurred you've mentioned about people
losing elements of themselves and
feeling some sort of mortal threat
i was trying to roll that forward into
some other situations okay so let's look
at both of those so first off yes
grievance is always a pathway to
indoctrination if you're not careful if
you are i just lost my 22 year old cat
last week and he was but you know i've
lived with him in seven apartments in
three states like he was very meaningful
to me and for a few days after i was
kind of walking around just like keep
expecting to see him and he's not there
and that puts you in a particular state
where you're more open for information
and potential indoctrination if someone
slips in and be like oh you're not
feeling good well i have this thing
try it out maybe it'll make you feel
better oh it's a breathing technique
wow i felt really bad for three days now
i'm doing this breath work and i feel
amazing this person is amazing so yes
absolutely on that level
back to the pyramid idea and this might
be where some confuse and have confusion
happen
privilege often means that you get so
accustomed to your lifestyle like the
fact that i can set my thermometer to
whatever i want and be a live at that
you know that very thin range of
homeostasis in terms of what i can
tolerate um that's not reality that's a
comfort that certain people have
but
when we think of survival we're thinking
of oh i just need something to sleep
under and some food but that's not how
we actually think of survival we think
of it as whatever level we are at and
then on top of that we're
constantly aspiring to higher levels
which in america specifically usually
has to do with
income or things that we own or can
acquire quickly and so that's
specifically what i meant when i was
going through that pyramid idea is that
people had what they thought was their
survival threshold and then that was
taken away from them and some people we
talked about humility some people was
like oh wow
i can live with less i actually feel
better with less but that wasn't the
case for everyone
what types of people become conspiracy
leaders if you were to create a
on average avatar what would be
what would the traits be
they
usually i mean they have
most of the time they have some presence
they're able to communicate within the
mediums of whatever they're working in
and so
a number of our figures were brick and
mortar that meaning that they ran
workshops they were public figures in
real life that they were able to
translate through their technology and
then some people are just fantastic on
tik-tok they know how to edit and light
and they know the keywords they know
they're telling me that
a feeder mechanism for cults oh
absolutely oh god okay
dude i am so glad of all of the vices
that technology's given me and the
whatever the
synapses that have been laid down the
fact that tick tock isn't one of them is
something that i'm going to be eternally
grateful for just having never
downloaded
yeah i i occasionally will post but i
never scroll the feed it's even for my
gen x brain it's too much laying down
that myelin's dangerous man you do not
want to get into that rhythm
right right and i have i have friends
who i'm 46 and i have friends my age or
older who that is their that is their
addiction they got into that that quick
niche and i'm like no i can't do that um
often times with the the and i'll use
the term grifters because a lot of these
people are grifters and one question we
often ask and
it's very hard to
ever indicate intentionality with
someone it's just it's impossible unless
you specifically know them and you know
why they're doing it
but
um
i always wonder with some of the figures
do they really believe this or do they
just see an avenue to modernize
monetization
[Music]
and
that is very difficult to assess at
times but i will say that what usually
cuts across the board with the
influencers is that they're selling
something and whether that is direct
with again supplement nootropic like
course whatever it happens to be or
whether that's just your attention for a
future project or book sale
they are dealing in the attention
economy and they want as much of it as
possible turned onto them and what
they're saying and i'm pretty
uh confident in saying that cuts across
the board
would that not be the same with say you
guys though you know you have a podcast
you need people to you you think that
it's interesting and of value therefore
more people watching it is good where
what's the distinction with the con
spirituality guru where did they take it
to one step further there
sure uh well in terms of the
monetization the three of us work
separately i work full-time um we have a
patreon and
my feeling has always been
you will allow us if you really find
value in our work you'll allow us to to
do more of it if you support us but less
than one percent of our listenership
supports us on that mechanism um so we
don't sell anything i mean we do have a
book coming out now as well i saw the
announcement congratulations thank you
that's and but the three of us are all
writers we're all trained writers so
that was always a goal was we were we've
been writing articles and such uh along
that and and of course yes i i want to
be successful i want to sell books
i completely understand them i
understand that fact and agree with it i
think that and again this is where it
comes into intentionality and it's so
hard to to really understand
um
i am going to
put forward the work that i've
investigated and feel is true if i'm
wrong on something we've made
corrections on the podcast the top of
every podcast
leaves us room to be like hey we said
this thing and we were wrong
we own up to when we are wrong we also
own up to when it is speculation
because some things we know for sure and
sometimes when we're riffing on
something we will always say
we don't know this but we're gonna
speculate on this right now and it fits
into a dynamic but we're not sure on
that
that is something that you don't find
with a lot of the infl or all the
influencers i think that will always
posit themselves as an authority as the
authority and the humility that goes
along with it is usually some sort of
just fake humility it's just like i
don't know this but i know this and
and that i think is an important
distinction um i think you are
completely correct in calling that out
and it's tough to assess
so it's really up to every individual to
put forward what they think is the best
information and that's the
standard that we try to hold ourselves
to yeah i think one of the challenges
that you have is that
feedback as well to the creators is
always going to be difficult especially
as you start to scale up because you
when you first start out maybe you could
read all of the comments but after a
little while you go i if i tried to take
on board all of this information i
wouldn't do anything else outside of it
and also i don't know how many of the
people that are feeding this back up
actually have
my best interests at heart how many of
them actually genuinely understand and
abort into what we're trying to do how
many have just stumbled here randomly
because of the internet one thing that i
notice
is
um
rare but
i find to be a very um charming element
that people that i listen to have
if they are receiving criticism or if
they're going through a difficult time
or whatever a degree of vulnerability
and openness around that
i i see that a lot of the time
very rarely would i see some of the sort
of conspiratuality influences
ever
genuinely seem to emotionally connect
with the uncertainty that they have the
uncertainty would always seem to be
quite performative
it would be
there as a smoke screen for them to sit
behind
um that you know like the just asking
questions type yeah
scenario um whereas
some of the guys that i just said lex
friedman's a good example of this like
he's someone and not con spirituality
like at all he's like nerd spirituality
um but he he is somebody who is
he genuinely connects emotionally with
the fact that he is more ignorant than
he would like to be
um and i have faith therefore that when
he messes up
it's inc you know he was doing his best
to try and do things and i hope that i
try and do the same on the show too um
however
you know there's an endless litany of um
people who are
more
uh unscrupulous with the way that they
go about
performative
ignorance or uncertainty and sort of
this lack of emotional connection
i spent my life in media interviewing
people it's my favorite one of my
favorite things to do i've done
thousands or thousands of interviews and
my feeling is always
that if i don't know something i'm gonna
find someone who knows it and identify
them and talk to them about it to get
their information so as i mentioned we
had just done an episode on
germ theory
uh i listened to this conversation
between two pseudo-science grifters
about terrain theory
i could tell it's [ __ ]
but i couldn't tell why it was [ __ ]
so we have a friend who has a phd in
molecular biology named dan wilson he
runs a channel called debunk the funk
yeah i've seen uh he's been doing loads
of stuff right during code yes yes so i
pinged him i said he's been on before i
said hey you've covered these guys i'm
trying to make sense out of this
can you come on and explain why this is
[ __ ] and he did and that comes out
next week
and also
you know i keep referencing this this
incident but it is pretty fresh with the
rogan thing
i mentioned
all of the
the
you have to apologize
grief that i got
but i also had a number of people reach
out to me and be like hey we love you
we think this is wrong here's why and i
was able to invite two of them on to the
next podcast to talk about why they
thought i was wrong and have
conversations and at that time i just
switched to journalist mode i just asked
questions i didn't push back i wanted to
hear their perspectives and release it
out there and so if you listen to that
episode
you're going to hear
myself and julian who have our
perspective matthew has a slightly
different perspective on it and then
you're going to hear a a
infectious disease epidemiologist and
then you're going to hear a civics
activist all chime in on this one topic
taking it from different angles and
finding where we disagree and agree
and that also is something that i just
don't see
happening in the conspiratoriality realm
people will only talk to the people that
already agree and you're not going to
see any sort of debate happening on
their feeds and that's unfortunate as
well
we've invited a number of the people we
cover on the podcast and so far only
charles eisenstein has ever accepted and
came on for two episodes and
still don't agree with what he's saying
but i appreciate that he was willing to
take the time and engage in that level
and that is really really important i
think the binary that you have with
regards to debate one of it being
the um
like ethan klein stephen crowder
and sam cedar situation which is
kind of this super performative you know
even the um
i think one of them
their wife was ill or whatever before
the thing started and they were
recording prior to like the the
broadcast beginning and even that was oh
i'm very sorry about that and you think
that's that's what a person that would
care would say um i didn't really trust
the like non-performative part of that
however um you do get to see really only
total sort of myopia and um
an insular containing of just speaking
to people that agree with the views or
on the other side of that if it is going
to be a debate it's bare knuckle guns
out
everything going and you know the
version that you've had there which is
kind of a reasonable can we get
somewhere closer to the truth
that's i mean one of the reasons that
it's not
done as much is that it doesn't get as
many clicks you know if you decide to
dunk on someone or
use the
sarcasm muscle to try and make them seem
stupid with you know like side eye jokes
and little giggles and stuff like that
that's going to get your audience more
riled up or at least the um
less
gracious elements of people's like
natures within your audience which maybe
they would even fact check themselves on
and go this is activating a part inside
of me that i really wish it wasn't um
but that's why
certain people
gravitate towards certain creators
because they continue to press that
button they continue to trigger that
reaction in them
right and
you know it it is challenging for me
operating in this medium uh one twitter
feed i follow is the the governor of new
jersey but it's it's not him running it
it's uh i'm from new jersey so it's it's
it's just a sarcasm twitter feed and in
fact the other day there was something
about like what is the native language
of new jersey and they responded sarcasm
because it's just it's so in me and so
sometimes it's hard to you know stop
that impulse
and yet the medium doesn't allow for it
but in terms of the debate and the
ability to have discourse with people
my academic training is in religion
and
i didn't grow up with one i feel
fortunate that i got to college having
no religious training whatsoever
i found psychedelics i found a few
eastern texts and off i went and that
began my exploration and one thing about
studying comparative religion without
having been brought up in one is that
you can read all of them you can find
through lines you can find points of
disagreement and then you can kind of
assess oh what's good from this that i
can take what should really be left
behind and look at him from that sort of
perspective
and that was very important to me as i
continued working and as i mentioned
traveling in my work and meeting a lot
of different people is that ability to
relate to something that they understand
without having this but that's wrong
immediately
put on them uh and
that's just so hard
to do in these mediums they're they're
easier to do in long-form podcasts and
that's one reason why i think they've
proliferated over the last few years but
in the general like low attention span
mediums that we use it's it's quite
impossible
how effective is the platforming when it
comes to
curtailing the growth of certain
creators because i've kind of heard two
sides of the story here one being that
you get this streisand effect where it
brings more eyes to people and they're
gonna grow in any case in different ways
and blah blah but then
my senses
at least in my opinion that doesn't seem
to be true like when you you essentially
unperson somebody when you take them off
of social media and they're out of sight
and out of mind
that is a question that
lies at the heart of our book in many
ways and
we had imran ahmed who was the founder
of the center for countering countering
digital hate in the uk on one of our
very first episodes to discuss that
topic and now we want to talk to him
again almost two years later because
there are varying opinions on that
what i will say
is that
with conspiracy influencers in
particular
they will announce they're leaving
facebook or instagram for telegram
for a year
every day or week
because they actually realize that those
other channels don't have the same power
for them and so they'll keep announcing
they're leaving but they don't actually
leave until they get de-platformed
they're kind of predicting the writing
being on the wall it's going to happen
at some point it's going to happen at
some point and i need to prepare
but they also and they also some of them
it would seem that they do it
intentionally to put content that would
make them get kicked off
after months of hinting at they might
get kicked off
and you go to their telegram channels
and they've grown since some of them
have followings but not to the degree
that they do uh their influence
their influence in the p in their in
groups isn't necessarily going to lag
because they've if they've gotten them
into their telegram if they communicate
through signal parlor whatever they
happen to use it's going to be strong
you will also often find that on the
instagrams and youtubes they post much
more milk toast material but always tell
you go to telegram where you're going to
see the
real material about what they think so
it's kind of layered here some some of
them will you christian northrop is an
example of one who uses her main
twitter facebook for the very vanilla
sort of material and then telegram is
just all out nazi material like straight
up here's a question for you if somebody
is
using
a
platform
which has stricter uh
terms of service like a twitter or a
youtube as the front end of the funnel
to get people into another platform
which doesn't and that other platform
has
um nefarious nasty stuff on it
i think that it's still too new to tell
that for sure meaning that a lot of
these people have been building up their
followings for years
and so it's more reactive now they use
those main channels to get them over but
they didn't set out with the intention
of that i understand my question is if
they're saying
reprehensible [ __ ] in a telegram do you
think that people should be removed from
youtube or facebook or something else if
they're driving do you think that
perhaps there should be some kind of
cross-pollination
between different platforms for you to
be do you understand the problem that
i'm talking about yeah no that's that's
too dicey that's too dicey i mean one of
the things you'll often hear them say
freedom of speech freedom of speech
these are private companies and if you
start having private companies working
together on that level that gets really
dicey there i i would not i would not be
for that idea um but we you you do have
a bit of an information hazard here
right that you can have the well-wrapped
version of somebody on the platforms
that are discoverability and then you
can have the
nastier version of someone on the
platforms that are more protected
it is it is a challenge but i just i've
worked in technology too long and and i
feel i do like freedom of speech is an
important aspect i i think that
identifying misinformation that's
harming people uh should be removed but
if you're talking about ideas and then
platforms that gets too far afield for
me yeah i understand
is it possible i had this question asked
me the other day do you think it's
possible to have an ethical cult
are you talking to jamie wheel no no i
wasn't actually no
i had him on the podcast about a year
ago talking about that okay is it what
did you come to is it possible to have
one
i don't
think so i think that
i i think that as soon as you label it a
group or a cult that
history shows that power dynamics
always come into play at some point as
soon as you start to scale
it it becomes too dicey for that i think
that if you're talking about a small
gathering of people who have a certain
mindset let's take an ayahuasca circle
and so they say you always do with these
10 people you have your corondero and
you have your ritual you don't need to
label it something you're not trying to
put it out into the world it helps you
it has some meaning we don't need to
call it a cult we you know it could be a
gathering of friends as soon as you
start to scale and you're getting to
hundreds of thousands of people but you
want to say it's ethical i
human nature just shows that it's very
difficult to actually pull that off
there's too many competing interests at
that point
that's why in conspiracy we'll see that
these people come together for online
conferences but you're not going to see
them working together on their own
platforms too often there's too many
cults of personality to be able to pull
that off
so
what part of what you're asking is is a
leaderless cult possible right because
that cult is usually defined by the
leader and as soon as you have one
figure to point to then there's going to
be power differentials that happen even
with the best yoga instructors who are
not cult-like that i followed their
assistants and the people closest around
them would start to form these tribes
around them where they practice in the
room how they talk to it like so i i'm
not confident it could ever be pulled
off but you end up with clicks in
crossfit classes right you know you have
you always have the same guys that'll do
the same class at the same time and then
the stronger dudes and
you know the better looking girls that
wear the smaller hot pants or whatever
um yeah it's it's an interesting one i
uh i've jokingly been referring to
like at the the pin the pinned comment
on the top of
um the time stamps is uh hello cult
members like here's the time stamps and
now i'm uh second
questioning whether or not you can even
use cult in a
like ironic uh satirical sort of
non-true way i don't even know if i
wonder whether it's such a dangerous
term that you can't even really use it
it's challenging you know people have
pointed out that colts is the root of
culture and i get that i was a group
fitness instructor at equinox for 17
years leading into the pandemic
i
i i completely experienced that the same
40 50 people in the room every week that
was their part of their practice and
they were there the question to me then
becomes
are we having this experience in the
room together that's very powerful
but then i as the person leading it am i
trying to take it out of the room
and that's that's something i was always
extremely careful i got into fitness
predominantly for physical and not
spiritual reasons and i try not to cross
that line the entire time so if people
asked me what to do to protect their
knee i'd give them an answer if they
started asking me something metaphysical
i'd say i'm not your guy
so i think that line is extremely
important to find and that and that's
why that's what i mean by scaling
you're in the room with the people you
have an experience awesome we don't even
need to label that
but once you take it out of there and
start trying to attract people in then
it becomes problematic yeah i understand
okay so as long as i don't get a god
complex then i'll at least be okay for
now so i saw this um i don't follow paul
graham although i i probably should do
because i keep on using his stuff
so this tweet from him uh yesterday
while the far left and far right have a
lot in common the far left is more
ideological than the far right while the
far right is more into conspiracy
theories than the far left interestingly
this means far-right nonsense is more
likely to get banned than far left
nonsense far-right nonsense gets
censored on social media far-left
nonsense becomes hr policy what's your
thoughts on that i don't really know how
to take it okay i'm just hearing it for
the first time so i want to make that
clear uh i just did an episode on
horseshoe theory recently which a lot of
people push back against um
people that don't know yeah sure
horseshoe theory is this idea that was
developed by this researcher called fey
it had to do with nazi germany and this
group that broke off of nazi germany
nazi germany who were anti-capitalist
and so they disbanded from hitler and
they started their own group and the
idea was they were very left of what he
was promoting and so the idea is that
once you get to like that politics is
not a straight line that it's a
horseshoe that the closer you get to the
middle the more the people get along and
then as you go up that the far left and
the far right will start to meet
someplace
now
i think this is true in terms of
sentiment and not necessarily policy
because the policies what he says about
hr rooms
the policies of the left and right will
manifest very differently
what i focused on
and i
admitted that it does not have to
necessarily do with phase original idea
on this
but is that the more dug in that people
get on the left and right the more
they're unwilling to engage with ideas
that don't conform specifically to what
they're saying
i would not say
that the far right at this moment is
necessarily more conspiratorial that's
the entire field of coverage that we're
doing now that said baked into the term
conspiracy theory is the far-right
conspiracies and the ideology that pulls
them over
but at this moment in history the left
is coming up with plenty on their own at
the at their fringes
um so but when you that's in terms of
sentiment when you step back and look at
policy then you're you're you're you're
a completely different world so you have
one world that is
in good ways i think trying to make a
more equitable world across genders and
across races
at the
worst extreme they're focused more on
renaming schools than actually trying to
instill a better economic system and
actually work on the policies that would
do that
in the far right you have stuff that i
generally disagree with a lot more which
has to do with you know
transgender rights gay rights abortion
rights things of that nature so it's
very split apart there so my top line
thought from that is it's just it's a
little too stereotypical to really make
an impact there there's there's so much
going on between sentiment and policy
that it's hard to discern what he was
actually driving at
what are some of the far-left cults that
have been what are like the most popular
ones that have been going on uh i mean
in in terms of what we cover i i
there we can debate whether or not you
can call them cults um because again a
cult is usually defined by having a
charismatic leader okay and right now
you have a lot of different people who
are just putting forward their
viewpoints and they tend to be boosted
up but there is no single leader
of any of these ideas at this moment
it's just a conglomeration of a lot of
people um but it really it has to do
with the anti-vaccination it really
rooted there and then spread out from
there so from anti-vaxx it got into
anti-mask and the efficacy of masks um
and from there it just got and this is
where the crossover happened that some
of these influencers then turned to
tactical training
and
armed training which i'm not anti-gun
but watching people who are yogis then
start to say we need to protect the land
and then start to create actual physical
communes which is happening right now
we've identified at least two
um that's where the the crossovers start
to happen
and you see a lot of people who were on
the left in terms of sentiment crossing
over into that space right now
wild man the internet's a crazy place
it's the craziest
uh derek barris ladies and gentlemen if
people want to keep up to date with what
you do where should they go
everything filters off of derek
barris.com uh and conspirituality.net is
where we host our podcast dude i
appreciate you thank you for coming on
yeah thank you chris appreciate it
what's happening people thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
episode then press here for a selection
of the best clips from the podcast over
the last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace